thank you that kind of looks like some
like prada versace
it's uh it's a it's a little sneak peek
it's going to come out late later
feel on this
did you know what's crazy about ila is
that she's already showing
yeah she's already got a belly kind of
it's crazy
i am
um
also i'm having a really weird thing
where i'm like
starving but then i don't feel like
anything oh
bro
yeah like yesterday yes
kind of a nightmare you guys understand
what my life is i'm literally just
feeding people that's my life every day
all day i'm feeding the dogs nobody in
my life wants to eat i don't understand
it the dogs don't want to eat
theodore is becoming a picky eater he
wasn't now he's becoming a picky eater i
got to figure out what he wants to eat
elo of course
it's about my whole life at home it's
just feet trying to figure out what
people i don't know what happened the
first week of this
pregnancy i was like eating anything i
don't know something happened
well we said when ela when you became
less hungry we were both like i don't
think you're having multiples yeah
on the way to the doctor to find out if
it was multiples or not
and we were both like i don't think it's
triplets anymore because you're not
hungry as hungry yeah
those first days you were like voracious
maybe it's just that um if i was
to get
sickness
um i would be throwing up but i'm like
this is my version of oh you think this
is your version of sickness do you get
sick already
i don't i don't think but i just feel
like um i mean is this where you would
usually get morning sickness yeah oh
really oh interesting
it can be any point really it could be
throughout the whole thing
thanks great oh zach is back oh yeah
yeah
oh my goodness it's
gabe
are you in a movie theater
oh he's muted and he's in a movie
theater
gabe is calling us from a movie theater
is his sound not working
there he is what's going on yeah
are you working
what
you're in a movie theater what are you
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
is there work or school tomorrow
we've missed you so much i don't know
yet
all right
gabe i'm gonna let you enjoy that film
okay i don't want to disturb the people
around you but thanks for calling in
okay checking in on us
sure all right
all right all right baby yeah we
appreciate you gabe friday friday love
friday
friday baby friday baby
okay okay all right
yeah just keep it down let's because
let's just yeah there's people around
you so let's just enjoy the movie okay
all right all right love you gabe
all right take care all right see you
next time yeah i'll see you on friday
buddy take care yeah take care baby
wow
gabe called us from a theater that's
amazing
next level oh he's still yeah he i love
how dedicated he is
yeah baby it's friday
it's friday baby
wow
gabe so dedicated
white claw gabe i cannot hype the man up
enough on tick tock on cameo
friday baby
that was maybe my favorite friday baby
ever you we had one from the baseball
game we had a mute one and now from the
theater bro
can be hard to top
it's friday baby friday maybe i'm sorry
um
[Laughter]
he started to get a little loud i got
worried yeah he's like dude you can't
keep the friday energies down
i don't know about cursing at the
theater it's friday baby
[ __ ] we're getting close to 3 million
that's crazy
oh
can we show it yeah wow so dan
noticed
i kind of uh
we're less than 300 away that's insane
dan noticed that we were gonna hit three
million on the show possibly
and being the sweetheart that he is he
threw up this counter
and so that's great that's pretty
exciting i am so excited
oh what the [ __ ] was that was that what
did you do
was there anything vital on there i saw
a money sign
[Applause]
great
but but wait is our people are seeing it
because i don't even see it on the
stream
yeah dude are people seeing the counter
dan
oh it's about to hit like what's
happening why are so many people
subscribing
oh [ __ ] oh my god
oh there it is insane what has happened
it just went to three what people wow
amazing
thank you guys what is happening it's
like it's like a subathon right now
holy [ __ ]
i gotta say
it's friday baby wow we just did like a
1500 in like a split second
i gotta say dude y'all are going crazy
over here let's go
oh we're about to hit 4 million at this
rate
you know i gotta say
usually
when i'm about to hit a big milestone in
subs especially live you get a bunch of
wise asses that start unsubbing
but you guys are such legends
wow such a dedicated lincoln
shredder
[Laughter]
you know what guys
wow that that that that's meaningful
thank you guys cheers
cheers and great job to you guys too i
mean this is a we're all celebrating
here
wouldn't be here without you guys that's
the honest truth
to the moon baby
i couldn't be doing this without you
guys that's just the truth you know
that's right
thank you thank you
you know i gotta say something y'all
we've been doing this podcast for a
while you know and um
sometimes the show through its course of
its kind of
broadcast has been like stagnant at
times when we've
maybe been in a rut creatively or i
myself have been in a rut creatively
but i want to say that um recently it's
just been so positive and so much
feedback and support
oh come on i'm trying to be sincere okay
play it i'll take it
and i just it's so meaningful it is
it makes me want to do this every day
and there were times in the not so
distant past where i thought about
quitting the podcast i really did oh
yeah
a few times yeah
no
but i just feel so encouraged
by the growth and by you guys and the
engagement we're seeing that i'm just
[Music]
i just
can i say i just love you guys i love
being a part of your week and i see how
important that is for people where the
like when we miss that episode they're
like oh
damn how am i gonna get through today
that means a lot to me
thank you wendy she's moved
uh
i don't know how to i don't know how to
properly express myself but
you're doing it well
i feel like it's not enough it really is
that
that much
you know
there's 85 foot so 85 000 foot soldiers
watching right now and that's just
yeah
wow it's just beautiful
and i just feel like all you guys have
are such talents so funny so creative
do you guys make this show great
each and every one of you it really
sounds like you're gonna have a
punchline i'm not there's no punchline
i'm waiting for it you know and this day
friday and even you love bot on the
especially you love butt oh thank you
he's got that what is that he's got a
kill he's got a kill
why are you wearing that
what happened that's delightful
to turn into an eight-year-old
but we love that he's digital he can do
whatever he wants
and ilo we cherish fridays because he
was here
yeah it's really fun
i just love having ila next to me just
like you know
my better half
people say better half but i mean it
no
oh stop it
you stop it anyway we do have a show to
do today so i'll try to
get off the sap
no thank you ethan we appreciate you
thank you a.b anyone else want to say
anything next to me ethan you are the
man ela you guys are the best and some
people in the chat are saying ethan
please stand up you can please stand up
[Applause]
so you should make a sound bites act
where it's like please stand up ethan
all right i'll i'll doctor one up yeah
you should do one for everyone frankly
okay i can do that anytime anyone's
under the gun just make him stand up
okay i can do it anyway today's by the
way sponsored by public and kraken oh
[ __ ] we're 10 minutes in that's all
right
it's a heartfelt moment cracking fair
enough so top of the show here
you know i hope you guys watched our
episode yesterday with bella porch
that was a very
she is such
an inspiring
person
her story is just like
unbelievable
and i feel like she gets a lot of hate
just for being popular on tick tock just
that's it just for being popular yeah
one of the most common comments i'm
seeing on that is like wow i
i'm so wrong about her and like the hate
and stuff and
honestly dude she's such an
inspirational person you guys should
really check that out if you haven't and
shout out to bella porch for coming on
here but yeah i mean they're
the reception has been
really nice to see
everyone's yeah it's cool yeah she's
super shy and really took i feel like
she took a risk coming out here in
public and doing like a full two-hour
interview so
yeah definitely a great watch
oh teddy fresh by the way if you guys
are wondering where my hoodie is quickly
this comes out on thursday of next week
the floral hoodie amongst a bunch of
other cool stuff yep we have a few quick
gaps that i want to share with you all
before we get into the topic of the
episode the real reasons for enemies
broke up i've got a whole
powerpoint essay
that you guys are going to be absolutely
compelled by but listen to this
okay i saw this dan sent this to me or
so i forgot one of you guys
is it the marvel thing yeah yeah yeah i
said a few okay so i saw this and i was
like
i was like i don't get the joke
so you know tell me if you get the joke
okay and i was first confused by it and
this is the first time for me in the
marvel universe this is
so do you get it is it edited yeah so i
was like why did someone edit this yeah
like i don't get what's the joke but
here's the real here's the real kicker
this is actual media from marvel studios
to promote that's owen wilson like
someone
like this is real media and then i
understood what was fun is the first
time for me in the marvel universe this
is the first time for me in the marvel
this reminds me when we would record our
old h3 videos and sometimes like one
take would really be so bad and you try
to we would call it frankenstein
you would really try to frankenstein and
put it together
cover it with the usually clip so you
can't see the horrible yeah
how bad could how bad could have his
take been oh this is the first time for
me and the marvel universe this is the
first time for me
in the marvel universe wow wow it's
awesome wow they're taking out all the
wows that's why it's so easy it's the
first time for wow me wow
i can't stop listening to this clip of
owen talking about loki oh we got to
watch that show by the way loki
uh of the new show loki yeah i haven't
um i i had a few friends reach out and
ask me if i was watching though and said
it was really good and they know that
i'm like kind of anti-marvel and they
were like but trust me you should watch
this one so i'm not considering it yeah
so he's in it
apparently this is to promote that he's
in it this is the first version i think
he's one of the main characters along
with the marvel universe along with loki
that does make me want to watch it
though i do like owen wilson yeah he's
good
but this is the first time before
what happened the marvel universe
this is the first time for me in the
marvel universe this is the first time
before me in the
universe that the marvel gets me it's
like the marvel
did they just say really slow and they
were like this has got to be like five
second clip you know
maybe spit it out but just do it again
for me i don't know i don't know what
happened but something terrible happened
i like the the person who tweeted their
comment that it just sounds like every
single word is from a different sentence
altogether that's what it sounds like
yeah this is the first time for he
brought they probably got him saying
marvel from a movie where he said
marvelous or something
marvel
yeah i love that you know we have a lot
of our owen wilson soundbites so that's
nice
wow
first time for me
and this is the first time for me
i think it has a filter on it too that's
why it's making me
the marvel universe
first time for me
could they not just be like hey me he
said it a little too slow can we do a
reshoot
i think they never thought they i don't
know what they thought bro i don't know
what they thought me
and
the
but so this is another thing that
happened
um
someone over hollywood
ian sent this to us
or well this is obviously someone else's
post but ian sent it as it was happening
someone was writing in the sky
and um
well here's the message they left
somebody got an airplane
went in the skies over los angeles and
left this message in the air joe rogan
is literally five foot three
i didn't know they had the technology
how do they actually do this because i
saw a video of it being written and they
do it like one line at a time like a
whole line
with like how is that how are they doing
this there's some software approach yeah
it's it's called digital sky writing i
looked into it and um yeah instead of
like the traditional way where they just
you know fly around and write out all
the letters they have some sort of
machine that releases yeah i'm just
surprised they can get that kind of
coverage because so it looks like it's
big mm-hmm i'm not a doctor i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how much does it cost did anyone talk
about cost
it's a at minimum it's like ten thousand
dollars so whoever wanted to do this was
willing to drop someone pay 10k for that
yeah
well i'm thinking i'm thinking like we
like wasting money we could totally do
this we could totally do this hp podcast
is live now oh my god friday baby
it's friday baby podcast is live we will
convert the whole city of l.a
this is crazy like you can spam the
whole city with a bunch of [ __ ] so the
thing is like teddy fresh new release
hours the thing is that like so we were
over on the 405 and we could see it from
there it doesn't cover as much as the
city as you would think but everyone
talked about it that's true it was quite
a bit because you guys yeah if you guys
were over with the 405 yeah we saw it in
hollywood i mean that's a that's that's
a decent way to come back
you spent on one um
sign is this legal
can you just go over the city and check
it out yeah next i don't think you need
a permit or anything can you just say
like something really obscene though
well like you know what i mean there's
got to be some limit right
i don't know i can look there's nothing
some sort of regulation yeah
oh [ __ ]
because if we go like yo hd podcast live
we're gonna have like the fbi probably
at our door being like uh you wanna tell
me about that a little bit
can we look into the let's contact
someone i wanna write some [ __ ] in the
air i'm doing some uh i'm doing some
research right now we saw it after this
and it said um
sincerely mike something yeah so he
wasn't hiding his identity well he
didn't write his last name he wrote
something i think it did oh i just
couldn't read it
apparently he there was also another
thing he wrote about like a proposal
someone got proposed to and then
then he dropped the joe rogan is
literally 5'3
is joe rogan 5'3 though i i thought he
no i'm not judging him i'm just
surprised by that fact google says 5'7
but oh
someone in the chat said someone did sky
writing to matt get gates no no i can
only imagine what that was about what
did they say to matt gay
wait let me see
maybe you guys can look i don't know
dude i'm fascinated by this
i can't believe that this is something
you can do with mike i mean epic it says
tick tock matt gates
oh like the clock ticking 99 000 people
watching live wow thank you guys damn
damn
love you guys
what's our sub count out because these
guys were going crazy i'm just wondering
how
how many uh let me check we're
we're already
almost 4 000 above the three million
marks
going to the moon baby on our way to
four million
um
that's actually that's really cool
because we hit two million i want to say
a long time ago yeah it took a long time
two to three battles yeah
it was it was a long time because a lot
of people came over from our main
channel but then it wasn't necessarily
for them you know so it was like right a
transition
the truth is though i had like
a long period of my mental health being
horrible
there was like two or three years where
i was kind of just worthless
i feel like and we were doing one
episode a week for a long time remember
yeah
episodes just didn't feel right because
we needed to learn how to do this right
it is it does take a long time to like
actually learn how to broadcast properly
but for a long time we were doing one
episode a week with just a guest so like
there was no time to build a real like
rapport with the audience
and i was just like struggling mentally
so i wasn't my head wasn't in the game
we kept trying different formats like
should we do 30 minutes without the
guest and then bring the guest or
you know we tried so many different
things a lot of experimentation yeah
yeah
yeah
well this is an amazing development in
my life that we can skywrite so let's
definitely look into this
h3 podcast i'm googling around right now
seriously compared to a billboard yeah
you get so much more from honeyfresh.com
i want to write all over the city people
are going to hate teddy fresh though
right that might be a bit much but hd
podcast is live is kind of amazing
i think we should do it's friday baby
just it's friday baby how does that help
me
you know you know friday friday baby dan
you just want to send out good vibes for
10k and i just i feel like uh paying it
forward to gabe a little bit you know
mm-hmm how about we just promote gabe
then white clock games
no we gotta do if hd podcast is live
it's friday baby woo and then woo with
like
oh i thought it was just like you go up
there one round oh man the cost is
probably once you're in the air you're
probably getting this balance yeah
i
have to find out
i wonder if you could like paint oh is
that jj that's project
oh i haven't heard that one it sounds
like gabe kind of yeah that's an
interesting similar engineer
another one
but i wonder if you could just like draw
a realistic like
phallus
yeah i've been googling around trying to
find laws on it and it it it kind of
seems like there really isn't that much
that's amazing but it seems like let's
make sure that they write laws after
we're finished with the sky
it seems like you people would be doing
that all the time if
well people don't have ten thousand
dollars to waste on some dumb ass joke
yeah this is a little different but i do
luckily
there's something called sky writing
which is uh using the smoke trails of a
plane to write something but that was
banned in 1960 oh it's banned
oh but that's but that's that's what
this is this one this one is because
this one's like a banner i'm talking
about like actual smoke like they're
isn't that no
that's what the joe rogan yeah the joe
rogan want to smoke dude yeah
but it's
the thing is i think they probably ban
doing it the traditional way because
they have to fly around really
it it's erratically
lots of noise pollution but with this
digital kind they just fly in a straight
line and it basically it's like a dot
matrix printer it just kind of
the matt gates one was a banner that was
just a banner yeah it's a tick tock matt
gates i don't want a banner i want yeah
the banners that's i mean the writing is
like i can never read the banners i see
them flying over santa monica over the
ocean i'm like whatever no the banners
suck banner saw i need this and it was
there for a while too that was what was
interesting yeah it was there for like
hours i felt like
i think it depends on the weather on the
day how fast it dissipates do you think
there's chemtrails in those oh hell yeah
they're dropping they're dropping the
vaccine on us baby
[Laughter]
yeah that's why it was abandoned what if
i wrote something like i'm dropping the
vac panic fool
panic mortals
there's vaccine in this panic mortals oh
yeah and someone is making me
uncomfortable if someone said in the
chat they spelled literally wrong
which is oh i didn't even think about
that it's stupid yeah they did guys
i believe they really i think they redid
it
but we did it
because there was a typo i forgot the r
yeah i think i saw a screenshot that
they like came back an hour later and
fixed it really
uh dude if you're gonna write in the sky
you better get your [ __ ] straight oh no
it's literally
literally
there is a debate about joe rogan's true
height though because he does say he's
like five
eight or something but if you look next
anyway it's all rabbit hole so
apparently this guy's invested
so he made it part of his engagement
um oh this is another great one this is
all top of the show stuff because it's
just so good i want to make sure we talk
about it so this is if we go way back
we had a huge debate on the podcast
about the sonic movie we were taking a
bat we were all like this movie is going
to be so horrible it actually turned out
to me be like
not
we all lost the bet because it ended up
getting like a normal rating yeah it got
decent reviews yeah we all thought it
was going to be the worst movie ever so
but because we were basing it on the
first trailer and everyone's like wow
this is horrible so they went and redid
sonic right
anyway should we give a trigger warning
to uh to sam before we discuss this
oh do you need a warning sam yeah damn
you might you might want to leave the
room leave the studio for a minute we're
going to talk about it
[Laughter]
so anyway we were all like we're going
to see sonic
and see how bad it is so ian
listen to this this is amazing
you saw sonic without taking a bite of
your burger tell me what you thought of
it yes um it was a good kids movie i
mean it wasn't didn't blow me away kids
movie look how young we look isn't that
crazy how long ago was this we all look
younger
look how
it was right before the pandemic it was
only like a year ago
yeah the sonic movie came out in
february of 2020. dude we have a lot
yeah that's the third time i mean we've
been through
the apocalypse in the last year wow
i still had hair a year ago
i actually didn't end up seeing it um
did you buy tickets and naco
uh yes that's correct
so you paid
you contributed to this
yeah i did notice i was confused because
he said he bought tickets until
something was off
we knew he bought tickets but he says i
didn't go but they came out now
just in the pre last week
ian told a story about well do we have a
clip to that story or time stamp oh no
but um
yeah ian told a story about how
him and his girlfriend sam
who also works for us now
uh went to sonic high and had panic
attacks sam said to ian he's so fast
and they both cradled each other in the
parking lot and just uh so so we found
out ian i don't know if you want to
speak on this but
people
put the dots together that you were
lying about things sonic because you
were so embarrassed about
sonic tripping you guys out from being
so fast ian
they
the h3 foot soldiers are very thorough
like how did they even remember that i
don't know i i know i know it's so crazy
dude i saw a post and i was like oh this
is the best and please stop
shout out to everyone on that on the
h3h3 production subreddit you all have
been absolutely on fire lately oh yeah
ian please stand up here's the clip that
exposed ian
here listen what did he what he said
last week
sam and i have have got high together
one time and it was so traumatizing
really again
we went and saw the sonic movie
oh really we went out of the house
wait i like weed high or something yeah
it was inedible yeah
yeah it's different we haven't tried
this specific one before and uh
yeah it came out on valentine's day so
we were like oh this will be kind of a
funny thing
and like
90 seconds in i just look over and sam's
gone
and i go out and yeah i go out into like
the lobby and she's just wandering
around looking like super terrified
and
i i go up i'm like are you okay what's
going on and she's like
he's he's so fast
yeah so what happened ian were you you
didn't you weren't ready to share that
story with us at the time
well i just didn't know if she wanted
that public yet and that's why i wanted
to check with her first
do you want to comment on this or no i
think at first we were just so
embarrassed
oh are you on a mic no actually oh she
says
you want to go with ian you can talk on
ian's mike or if you don't want to be on
camera that's fine too
yeah join
em so sam is coming over to explain
cover-up the sonic cover-up
by the way ian's shot it looks like just
a head floating yeah it's so dark
so embarrassed
and i don't know i wanted to keep it in
the tuck for a while but then we just
realized it was so funny
it is so funny yeah i know what you mean
sometimes you need some space
on the event before you realize it's
funny
then we
we went into a bit of a tails spin oh my
god and you could say we're get kind of
knuckles heads oh my god oh you saw that
coming i hate you because what this
sonic sidekick is called stand up and
tails and tails this is the other one
knuckles and tails were you prepping
when did you prep that oh i wrote that
about four weeks ago
two years ago before the pandemic yeah
wow
good job guys
i'm glad we got the truth ian don't lie
to me again
so there you go
shame
shame
shame lots of love
sam's llama
by the way oh yeah people were so happy
with sam's
uh llama for bella that was amazing i
thought um it's an alpaca
oh
my fault excuse me
uh it's an alpaca
oh there's one other thing i want to say
before we get into the main part of the
show here
i watch bo burnham special the inside
special on netflix
bro has anyone watched that i have not i
saw you were going off
first of all very good you were having
an exercise
i'm very worried about him
i just i'm very worried about him i want
him to be okay it's so depressing it's
like so
utterly depressing is it a comedy
special it is a comedy
but it's
very depressing you can just tell it's
really interesting i mean it's very good
you can tell it's both entertaining and
funny but you could just tell that he's
in like such a bad place bro it's just
like rough
but it's very good yeah that's wild
nobody's seen it though you guys should
watch it
all right let's move on to the main meme
let's move on to our ad reads because
it's that
okay this one i'm excited to do kraken
jesse from the kraken the guy who bought
our limited edition gold nft vape niche
afterwards i love this guy jesse from
kraken he came out he's like yo besides
that i want to sponsor i want to support
the show
this is such a great company kraken
dot com slash h3ad
jesse powell
for the last 10 years kraken has been
one of the best platforms for trading
crypto online now with the new kraken
app it's easier than ever to buy and
sell over 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies on the go 24 7. simply
download the kraken app connect your
bank account and start investing for as
little as ten dollars just a minute is
all it takes to get started
and with the new kraken app you'll have
your portfolio in your pocket wherever
you go monitor your investments track
winners and losers keep tabs on your
favorite projects or view the most
traded cryptocurrencies of the day
it's all it's got all the features you
need with none of the complexity it's a
simpler way to invest in crypto so go to
kraken.com
h3ad
so they know who sent you and once again
i just want to say
i know that this cracking company is one
of the longest standing most legit
uh trading platforms for crypto i know
this guy jesse is an ultimate dude a
great guy and uh he's just he's a fan of
the show supporting the show so we'd
love that good taste in nfts oh bro he
is what a taste maker
so go head on over to kraken.com h3ad we
love you jesse thank you
we got one more for you guys from public
[Music]
public this is a really cool one too i
like these guys today sponsor is
public.com an investing app where you
can buy and sell stocks follow investors
and share ideas so on here's the thing
public uh supports a bunch of people
like phil defranco emma chamberlain cody
ko
graham stefan i don't know who graham is
do you anyone know graham stefan
probably a great guy he's he's such a
good guy oh he is
okay but this isn't about gram seven
this is about public i'm on it too dan
swardlow from the h3 podcast
huh
dan swerdwa from the hdpogus loves
public.com he's about as famous as
graham stefan actually could someone i
want to see who this can you google
gramps
he's a real estate investor i believe
who makes youtube videos
grand stefan we love him let me get a
picture of this graham stefan character
this just turned into a weird big ass
promo for graham stefan
click all right get on track oh i do
know him actually love says he watched
all of his videos love how do you follow
everybody knows everything about you why
is it there what can i say i'm uh i'm a
youtube connoisseur yeah you're a really
valuable asset i actually have to say
because you know everything
so you like this guy graham graham staff
stefano oh yeah he he's like a economic
economic like youtuber it's a no wonder
that he loves public.com
h3h3
public is the best place to invest
especially if you're just getting
started the app is free and you can
start with as little as one dollar
that's what's kind of novel and exciting
about public is that you can buy slices
or portions of a stock instead of the
full share like if you look at amazon i
don't know what their stock is probably
like 300 bucks or something i don't know
for one stop
so you don't need 300 to buy
amazon with public you can get a slice
and get investing so it's it's great i
mean it's a great way to learn
and to grow your portfolio without
having to commit
a ton of money
doesn't sell your data or information to
third parties or market makers like
other investment apps you'll get a free
slice of stock what's funny
oh i just i looked up the stock price of
amazon you were off by an order of
magnitude a share of amazon is three
thousand four hundred and eighty six
dollars right three thousand
bro i wish i bought amazon back in the
day yeah right
i'm conflicted though because i hate
jeff bezos so much but it's like
you kind of gotta get in or get you know
what i mean it's like
he's still making money like crazy dan's
giving me this
probably not during the ad read but i'm
just saying it's a great stock to buy i
just don't like the guy yeah i
understand you know what i'm saying fair
enough i mean it's one of the best
stocks can just say you know
this is not investment advice no no no
no this is not investment advice
what the [ __ ] do i know about investing
you get a free slice of stock when you
go to public.com
h3h3 to download the public app get
started today and make sure to follow me
say what
follow me
you follow me
what's your thing how do they follow you
i think uh my username's just sword love
i believe my last name so public.com
wordlove
uh
yeah and then they can see what trades
you're making
uh yeah although it does give you if if
that freaks you out you can uh you can
set it to private
interesting
follow dan
uh this is not investment advice
once again make sure you go to
public.com h3h3 to get a free stock
slice
link is in the description thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
great sponsors today yeah
okay so anyway we're about to get into
the meat of it so thank you guys
okay here we go
the real reason frenemies broke up
the moment you've all been waiting for
okay i want to preface this
by saying that i'm not
my intention here is not to stir the pot
what i really want to do is highlight
all of the great content that came out
of this
okay
so you guys know that the three percent
thing was has been kind of a meme three
three
you hold my back oh my god bro
trish is like five
she's just watching at home she's like
five don't lie about me
you're changing the number
right out of the gate
off to a good start at one percent
the five percent
became quite an issue for tricia
and apparently for her whole family
because her sister
went to tick-tock
to talk about the day
well bro you get you gotta just watch
this because this one really kind of
i was like really okay so this for me is
when the five percent meme took off and
to be honest with you guys
i'm just trying to make the best of this
situation that is is quite sour to be
frank and so
i watch this with peace and love
i watch this
with peace and love just for the memes
okay i do have a
little disclaimer to make should i do it
now go ahead i just want to say i know
that there's a lot of heated
um
people following this situation because
of course it's
a crazy one and we're all following it
but
i just want to remind everyone it's real
people and
you know moses especially being my
brother
i just
would like to at least say like try not
to send hate
and
try to be mindful that they're still
real people
and
so they claim
so they claim i'm just i'm kidding i'm
kidding we're all real people we're all
real people but i know that right now
it's i'm kidding that we're all people
it's probably not easy on them right now
you're not saying that the truth
the
the voice of reason and serenity
no no hate and war
we want peace and love peace and love
only good you look good okay you got him
well stated well stated stand up villa
did you get it
hey let's stand up do you we have the
sound
stand up
i i will put that together after the
show
um with that being said okay so anyway
thank you thank you for the disclaimer
yeah don't send hate please
um they are people but you know i'm just
i'm trying to i'm trying it's funny it's
funny and i need to cope
i am a comedian or you know fine but i
tell myself or
i don't necessarily believe myself
either but anyway here's the video and
it blew my tits right off my fat body
that's a new one
now that's a sound bite
so there's three parts
to make it
okay let me let me just start over
because i don't want to miss a moment
dan you might want to crank it a little
bit
this is important
so you can pause to read this but um
i want to make it known that he didn't
even take the time or effort to watch my
sister's
video she was just doing a trigger
warning to people
that had essay because she was talking
about the handle stick incident
so this disney trip was actually planned
um for my sister's birthday it was me my
mom and moses and that was it
um
i know that
they were at a
family event
um at ethan's house and
ethan
incidentally invited himself to
our family surprise um
and
we paid for him ethan and ela did not
pay for their vip ticket to disneyland
and
um there's more
that's part one
dude it's so
so hard probably it's just you gotta
understand how hard it is for me to not
say anything about that it's impossible
look
she's calling me out publicly and then
they say oh ethan's not supposed to
respond
she ended up removing them right well
just for the record
yeah she removed them when everyone's
like you're really complaining about
disneyland what is wrong with you
but i'm just saying she thought she was
doing something okay let me let me
respond
so this is the real reason we broke up
apparently
so she's first of all saying we invited
ourselves to her surprise party
this is where it's just so frustrating
for me
you know we we obviously didn't invite
ourselves we were invited
as trisha even says in her video it's
like they can't even keep their stories
straight
we were invited
was that the only accusation she made
there because it keeps going the best
part comes later
but yeah trisha says we invited them
graciously she says
anyway here's the best part
um
she made a three-parter
yes my sister didn't know about this but
um we
end up paying for ethan neela
which is
crazy because he takes that five percent
and vip tickets to disneyland is not
cheap this is that was by far my
favorite the clan is that i take the
five percent therefore i need to cover
every cost in their life
and i was like what can't this five
percent cover
why i the fact that i haven't ended
world hunger and poverty with my five
percent it's just that it's insane it's
irresponsible
so
she said again
but like it's so funny okay first of all
like they
there's just so many layers bro they
invited us and now they're complaining
that we didn't pay for our disney ticket
he takes that five percent but i
actually have to say
is that we begged them
i begged them to let me pay
you think i wouldn't beg them to let me
pay i'm not a freeloader
they're making it sound like a percent
they're making it sound like i'm
freeloading disney tickets
i'm talking about skywriting some
[ __ ] in the air for ten thousand
dollars i don't care about the price of
disney tickets but i beg them to pay all
along the line i beg them
i bend them pay for the tickets
i asked are you sure you don't mind us
coming no we love you uh you're you're
my friend i always go with my family
only i'm so happy that i have friends
coming
and now it's like
you get five percent you didn't even pay
for the tickets
i'm sorry
that is [ __ ] hilarious
it's like the five percent has become
this dialogue in her whole family it's
like they're all just sitting there
counting the five percent like it takes
that five percent you got her whole
family you're just like the five percent
five that's a small number one two three
four five out of a hundred it takes a
hundred numbers there's five of them one
two three four five that's it
how much should i take for production
costs one a quarter percent five percent
you should be paying
i am paying
so she goes
they didn't even pay for their tickets
by the way just to clarify because i've
done the vip tour a shitload of times
okay
and how it works is you pay a flat fee
hourly
and it doesn't matter how many people
you even bring up to 10. so the fact
that she's even saying we didn't pay for
our vip tickets is is funny considering
that the vip tour price literally
doesn't change for the amount of people
you bring up to 10 people it's a normal
disney ticket
five percent i was like i was like
what's her name callie or something
i said kelly you know what with my five
percent just send me your send me your
rent
send me your bills trisha moses
everybody mom send me all your bills
come on i've got the five percent give
me give me give me give me give me and
you guys are buying a new house i'll
take the mortgage on that i got it
i just don't get it why do they do this
and you know trisha went off about how
jeffree star like hangs up hangs like
the did the
vegas trip over her and then you got her
out here talking about five percent and
100 disney
tickets
and then they go he didn't even pay for
dinner he said he was gonna pay for
dinner he did i begged
we all offered him begged we offered so
many times but trisha was like i love
playing it's my birthday i love paying i
took out my car i said no no no take it
take my car take my car take it she goes
no no no no no take it take it take it
no no no no no no no i love paying for
stuff take my card i said i was going to
buy dinner i wanted no and then like
fast forward of that five percent and he
didn't even pay for dinner i'm saying
i'm sorry
i said you guys send me the bill i'll
pay it even to this day
send me the bill
in fact i have trisha's payment info i'm
gonna include an extra thousand for her
just for the troubles pain and suffering
and interest as well
i'm gonna send her a thousand dollars
you know
she can give that to callie
since they're so disturbed but the thing
that really rubs me wrong is that like
you know
that if cali is saying this it's coming
from the whole unit of people that
they're sitting there circle jerking
about the five percent loss anyway
that's that i'm gonna keep playing it
five percent
and i i don't know why he felt compelled
to ask
me and my mom or bring it up in the
situation that
how we felt about her
having a candlestick up her
you know what it made us very
uncomfortable especially we had just
such a fun day
and it was really disgusting uh i think
that he wanted the shock value but i
think that he forgets that they really
think i was doing that on purpose i just
can't stomach that yeah
i mean we did a whole episode about how
i was embarrassed about it exactly
they like spun this narrative that i'm
like trying to embarrass the whole
family you said to yourself we've had a
really nice day together i'm not trying
to the thing is that throughout the day
we were talking about how they watch
frenemies all the time dude they knew
every detail of the show i can see why
you thought you know that it would be
okay to bring it up
they knew but still when you did we were
just like i wasn't don't bring it out
you know whatever and then we all moved
on yeah i saw it missed and i felt
really bad and you know
it's just i don't know yeah i'm sorry
about that you know it was embarrassing
for me
but on the flip side oh god don't say it
ethan
callie
no no i'm not going to say it i'm sorry
we're
family at the end of the day
i was not appreciative of that
especially since we paid for everything
even we paid for the dinner
we had to pay for it
yeah
i wouldn't have been so offended if
ethan would have paid for something
we don't care about money by the way
since we paid for everything even we
paid for the dinner he wanted to pay for
you didn't pay for [ __ ]
for a dinner
exactly we did and then trisha didn't
let us i'm supposed to argue with her
like you know what when you're you see
your aunt so arguing with the car like
i'm gonna pay i'm gonna you want me to
argue with her for an hour let me to pay
just pay i'm not gonna [ __ ] like the
scene okay i don't care that much i
offered to pay i said i was gonna pay i
took out my car we had a little tiff and
i said you know what if you want to pay
them [ __ ] pay i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not gonna flip the table and cause
the scene and start yelling i don't know
what you want from me
call ahead of time hey just so you know
we're gonna be coming to your restaurant
around 5 p.m this girl trisha or cali or
someone's going to try to pay reject
their card cut it in half with your
scissors
do not accept payment from them it's
like what length do i need to go just i
said i would pay just let me pay i don't
understand the whole [ __ ] hub bub he
takes that five percent
oh it's so frustrating this is actually
the issue they're bringing up like this
is the stuff that
the show broke up over
the five percent the disney tickets
anyway so there's that part
and he takes that five percent and you
know i wouldn't have been so offended if
he would have just paid
for something that sounds genuine
i was disgusted especially considering
we paid for everything
sounds genuine dude
sounds like you were really offended
if he would have paid for dinner i would
have let it slide and not made this
video
and this one is for the people that
think that i
solely work for my sister or needed a
job at h3
um i actually worked for myself i have
my own business
as a spicy accountant and
um
yeah i was trying to figure out what a
spice accountant us that's what i heard
too what is this what the
hell is that
the spice accountant
i mean i know she has like maybe spice
is a uh an acronym for yeah because i
know she has like a of account i think i
thought it was spicy content i heard
spicy content oh oh okay
yeah that makes sense
she makes spicy content oh
wait what
because she does you know
i don't want to say anything vulgar but
i see accountants you know what she
means
okay spicy content yeah spicy content
i got it
spicy content because it's just such a
weird way to phrase it i don't know i
mean i agree she may have a spicy
accountant we don't know
what does that mean accounting for like
a spice shop spicy my account attitude
they got oregano you know
accounting for the five percent
dude my account takes more than five
percent no
i'm just saying what can you get in life
for five percent what can you get in
life for five percent
it doesn't seem like a lot
it just doesn't
i'm sorry it just isn't a lot
okay and then this last part was great
too because there's this whole weird
fantasy narrative that trisha dreamed up
after after the breakup that i was
supposed to hire her sister this was
never brought up to us
first of all trisha told me she used to
work for her and then she made her own
spicy content and now she's killing it
and doesn't and she says i have trouble
finding an assistant because i only like
working with family
i was like
who said she's looking for a job
i didn't know she was even looking for a
job she says herself she acts like i was
trying i didn't
thought she was talking about hiring her
this is nothing
it doesn't exist
this that doesn't exist
nobody's hiring her
it's not even a conversation we ever had
all of a sudden everyone's talking about
hiring callie i was like what
yeah when i'm done hiring kelly i'll
hire the pope to do our gaffing
a list of other people that i would
never hire and who aren't looking for
work
yeah when we're done let's get biden in
here to do some [ __ ] the lighting joe
biden
what
what are you talking about
anyway and this one is for the people
that think that i
solely work for my sister
maybe maybe this is a joke i think the
only person she goes and this is for
everyone that believes i was looking for
work your sister's the only one
this is a video for your sister to say
and for trisha
terry
um i actually work for myself i have my
own business
as a spicy accountant and um i highly
doubt that h3 could afford me i think
she is she is i've i figured it out yeah
that's an acronym people are saying
that's what people don't say
yeah oh if people say they're
accountants oh okay so so it was very
confusing it wasn't focusing i just
it was popularized by tick tock that's
why i love fans the [ __ ] are so
innovative bro i've learned new ways to
say [ __ ] to get around sensors that have
been so useful honestly
because when we do these live shows if
we mess around and say the wrong thing
the whole episode can get deemed so now
i'm talking about spicy accountants i'm
talking about essay
talking about you know and all these
things that you want to talk about but
it's great so she doesn't deal in spices
she does not uh she does not deal in
well she was never a dealer she just she
just did ran the numbers
for a dealer for the spices for yeah a
spice trader got it from the silk road
really needed some paprika
oh
a vendor so anyway she i like by the way
she says i doubt you could afford me
it's like i never ever i'm not eat i'm
not crunching the numbers i'm not
looking to hire you
by the way and then listen if she says
afford i'm sorry i know i'm being maybe
too much but i'm being extra but
and
um i highly doubt that h3 could afford
me a ford
i shouldn't i'm the guy you're the last
person okay
over here
singing
singing the other day you were really
hitting that
thing
so anyway you're right i couldn't afford
you and i have no intentions of of
fitting it in my budget nor did i ever
actually i was looking to hire um
uh
yeah i was looking to hire uh
someone funny to say
an accountant
like someone really high profile that
would never want to work for us
dave chappelle i was looking to hire
dave chappelle to do uh
to run research for us though he was
ahead of the list for you
and this is the first time for me
i was looking to hire owen wilson's
editor
in the marvel yeah by the way if i hired
cali this is what our editing would be
like play that owen wilson this is
callie's work this is the first time for
me in the marvel universe first i was
like wow callie great job on the editing
i'm glad i'm paying a hundred thousand
dollars a month
[Laughter]
well anyway
so this blasted off the five percent
meme because i was like
i was like wow this really is the real
problem the five percent
so
um
i responded a few tick tocks
uh here's my first one i made
this one i can't play the music because
i just played john lennon imagine all
the people
and it's just me welcome to utopia if i
saw world hunger probably with my five
percent
and then there was another one this one
came from the subreddit i think
and it was so funny
you know
um
richest people in the world bill gates
jeff bezos ethan klein five percent cut
from frenemies
and then the subreddit was just
exploding with these five percent memes
it was so good he takes that five
percent i know it's brutal
it's brutal it's just unfair to cause to
charge that much
so here i'm going to read some of the
ones from the subreddit ethan and dan
with the five percent of frenemy's gun
the gravity chair
i will i tell dad by the way if you want
that gravity chair it's in dan's court i
told him i'll buy it he's dragging his
feet
it's gonna happen he takes that five
percent
uh actual this is the actual photo just
off the camera
uh of the of the
studio with the five percent
you can see the users
after size yeah guys i want to say keep
those memes coming on the subreddit
because at this point we can make a
whole podcast episode just about the
subreddit memes
they've been really funny so good and i
saw someone i think it was a post at
some point like don't you just love
memes like it can really
bring uh so much comedy and humor out of
this situation that's what i love about
it
downtown l.a after you ethan uses his
five percent to give back to the
community
flying cars a perfect utopian
environment
a venezuela economy stabilizes by
donation from ethan clyde's five percent
trisha paytas has been quoted saying he
still owes me for disney
well there's money for everyone in that
five percent
oh
is that a little uzi vert's 20 million
pink diamond
next time we see ethan after he spends
that five percent
he takes that five percent
ethan collins net worth
he is a comedian with a net worth of
five percent
that's
five percent of friendlies
crazy that ethan makes this much these
are malaysian bamboo floors oh i don't
get this one i guess this is a deep cut
meme richest people in the world this
one we already saw
emergency alert the billionaire known as
h3 has just purchased the entirety of
the state of california with what he
calls the 5
enemies money
this is what trisha thinks is happening
with our five percent
[Music]
oh so funny you guys are so funny bro
[Laughter]
oh is that smog from the hobbit ethan
with this five percent i'm the dragon
smog governing my
stolen treasures
the five per oh this one's really good
the five percent
the highlights revenue oh [ __ ]
nothing could be true
but we haven't even
gone to that there's only a tip of the
iceberg boy
ethan and ela looking at the five
percent in the basement
hd podcast more like the h5 podcast
oh come closer
i need i need
five percent
uh they were so funny so you know what
guys though in seriousness
um oh we made our own memes eh
these are all original
oh this was cam grant's you know i love
this [ __ ]
me with the indiana jones you know from
later this was raiders of the lost ark
five percent
it's a heist
five percent of frenemies adsense it's
aladdin's uh the treasure those thinking
treasures
or something agrabah agrabad thank you
five percent cover so this is if what i
when i spend the five percent on love's
repairs
it turns into an actual uh
war robot instead
useful the five percent of frenemies
woeful wall street gag
we like that
that's it nice
but anyway in all seriousness guys i
know i'm just i'm having too much fun
here but
um
there is um something serious that we
prepared about the five percent that i
want to share with you guys now so ian
if you will do me the honors of playing
our five percent video
[Music]
lord ethan klein sits before you
to hear the petitions of the five
percent of my vast wealth i shall hear
the first commoner dan the producer come
before your lord please pay homage to
the ring
bow before me your grace thank you now
what would you like of my five percent
of vast wealth your grace i humbly
request
[Music]
but
a simple
sixteen thousand dollar zero gravity
workstation ah yes the zero gravity
workstation tis but a drop of my vast
five percent fortune consider your
petition granted
now please scuttle away president rooney
you are a lord amongst lords
away with him uh grant him the request
next up ian the employee please
present me with your petition please
humble yourself before the ring
no no no no no on all knees with your
forehead to the ring please can i get
like a mat or
no a mat
touch your forehead to the ring kneecaps
hurt a little bit okay all right okay
all right what would you like of me your
lord
of infinite vast wealth i was wondering
if i could maybe
get this this player suit
uh play a suit for mike warren
worn by will smith and bad boys too
unique purple player suit from bad boys
too worn by will smith a mere 1 million
dollars the shipping though is pretty
good
oh that is a good deal only 200. yeah
nice that's like a fraction of the cost
yeah consent to your petition granted is
a drop of my vast wealth of the five
percent of frenemies thank you sir thank
you for humbling yourself before me
good ian the next petitioner is a beast
come before your lord and humble
yourself
all right what are you doing then i'm at
santa claus bro sorry i'll be starting
off so though holiness not holy well
just gets the ring bro come on all right
what do you want i have a lot of
student loan debt student loan debt like
a hundred thousand
a hundred thousand in student loan that
a drop in my vast fortune consider it
granted what's what did you do really no
okay i do have like seventy thousand oh
seventy for what medical school yeah oh
no i need that one consider it wiped
away from your slaves thank you uh
[Music]
a mere drop in my vast fortune of wealth
from the five percent of frenemies the
next petitioner bring in zach the sound
lad you're my lord my lord thank you
please humble yourself before you be in
your presence
the 5 speaks for itself what can i do
for you please and your good grace is my
lord
go ahead can i please have paul newman's
17 million dollar rolex
17 million reference number 6239
please my lord 16 million
[Laughter]
a drop in the bucket of my vast wealth
here young zach oh my god of goodwill oh
my lord thank you my lord my lord i am
swimming in endless country oh my lord
thank you absolutely thank you my lord
go with grace
and the fight and service of the five
percent oh we have another request from
dan dan step before your lord
once again humble yourself yes thank you
my lord
i heard the other petitioners and i
realized i kind of lowballed you
hardcore with that sixteen thousand
dollars yeah seventeen million dollars
whatever your wishes so all i ask my
lord is for a vip trip to disneyland
disney tickets
oh i can't afford that dan i am sorry
that is well beyond my vast wealth of
five percent uh no out of the question i
uh no i am sorry uh please usher him out
[ __ ]
disney tickets is well beyond my sucks
all right calm down to it be humble
disney tickets is well beyond my means
of five percent so
oh that guy uh i believe the nerve on
that guy
so that's it guys
what do you all think
oh you've ever been yeah
that was fun
that was awesome that was super fun
so there you have it you know i can
afford everything in this world but uh
not disney tickets
how dare you ask that of me dan
he takes that five percent
yeah
love that was a lot of fun
so that's it that's the real reason for
enemies broke up
apparently who made the five percent hat
oh we just used so we used ian
did the fashion show oh yeah right that
was his triangle
that was his shungite
you know it's funny that that whole king
outfit was just from our existing props
we're starting to build quite a rep
repertoire repertoire yeah the sword was
from philadelphia yep
the the cape was just a red curtain from
the old office right clasped over me and
the money was from the uh idubbbz uh
ricegum video right from years ago yeah
yeah that's the realest looking fake
money i've ever seen i've done that okay
i had to double check it i was like is
there a real bill on top or something
when i found it i'm like oh [ __ ] this is
where it's higher the five percent
no it's it's locked away somewhere much
safer
well
it almost feels bad to move on because
it was so much fun but
but we have a really fun segment
actually the david dobrik's return no oh
we're almo well so yeah we're coming up
there's a few more things we're coming
up on
what we're going to do ultimately no i
want to do these is um
we have an international food segment
snacks snacks foods that we're all going
i'm not gonna chew into the microphone i
promise so don't freak out
but you guys hurt
i'm gonna do my best you know
but very good point dan
you know it's funny because once for
enemies ended everyone's been joking
that all these people came back david
dobrik came back yeah tati
came back people are happy to see tati i
didn't know people like tatin
but they're happy to see her apparently
tati jeffrey starr came back
you know it's kind of
what was that oh is that that was a tati
in the beginning of one of her videos
[Music]
very specific play that against that
hard to tell
seriously zach why would you pull that
well i think we i think it was already
pulled from one week
at the time oh cause she didn't cut it
yeah yeah
it was like the video started and she
was like
yeah i was being real critical of her
video
good job zach thank you
i don't understand your vast intellect
at times
it's clear to me now
so anyway you know david dobrik came
back and people really don't give a [ __ ]
it's pretty amazing
like if you go to his channel
dude people are so stoked to have david
back
um
you know i'll just show you we mentioned
isn't didn't shane tease a comeback oh
yeah shane is coming back as well right
yeah
but you know
um
6 million views and
700 000 likes
his views aren't saying i didn't realize
they're so crazy is that
like these ones have like 15 30 20
million holy [ __ ]
it's good to be david dobrik huh
and like he posted on instagram
and um 2.3 million so people really
don't care it's kind of amazing
you know
i feel like unless you get a literally
arrested then right nothing nobody cares
yeah like if you get arrested then
they'll be like oh okay
i understand
that's true i mean
yeah that's true even then
there's still cosby defenders out there
oh yeah
[Music]
yep bunch of them
cancel culture run amok speaking of
which this is kind of interesting
liza koshy
i saw that just came out of the closet
or i think i don't know why but i think
she made a post yeah everyone seems to
agree so i'm not speaking at a turn here
but i'll show you she made a post uh
with her
i think it's her girlfriend because i
mean correct me if i'm wrong but she
posted this photo
and she said happy belated birthday baby
i can't wait to see you at the end of
the aisle one day i mean
that's saying she wants to marry her
right i have no idea which role you'll
play like male or female or like the man
or the woman or whatever
so but that seems pretty clear what is
this that you just posted ian
i just saw that like a correction i
think
oh
wait what is this what does it say
explain yourself
oh she added to the description well
here it's in the description then i'll
just read it how about my efficient
flower girl usher
the redick hot bridesmaid that
effortlessly shows up direct regardless
you know wait what so she's saying it's
not a yeah
but then why would she write it like
that okay because i wasn't sure but then
i started trending and everyone's like
oh for sure she just came out now i'm
just confused yeah no there's a lot of
articles that uh we're saying a lot of
fans were speculating that she was
coming out so
well sorry
okay
regardless you know you'll be there
check your inbox for the picture list
so wait why would she say i'll see you
down the aisle one day
exactly got me with that sake yeah
like i don't know it's just
i guess i'm just confused i don't know
i think it's also that we just like
can't i don't know if pride month is
over but no it's just june it's all june
right
yeah
i really like that i really wanted to
feel like maybe that's kind of why
everyone immediately assumed too but the
way it was worded no i read it before
the edit and it it seemed
i mean it wasn't a direct confirmation
but um
one day yeah
which role you'll play
the f
you know she's in love
but i don't know what's happening
anymore
just best friends
yeah
okay so i take everything back
psyched out
i just got psyched out hard chet hank
style
but like okay i mean hmm okay it's up to
her it's her business you know i just
thought she was doing something so
take it back
regardless david is back and everybody's
happy to see him including trisha by the
way who tweeted something like
so happy david's back
i was like girl you can't you got me in
the trenches against him and you can't
even keep your [ __ ] straight
so anyway we got a sneak peek of some of
his videos coming up
it was actually leaked
um
lovebot zapped into his mainframe
and was able to uh
get a get a peek for on all the
thumbnails he's uploading it's weird
though that this one says one year ago
for example that doesn't make any sense
right it says one year ago
how odd point that out releasing the
unlisted collection um
here's one coming up
leaving mystery packages in public
places
and there's a swat team
that sounds pretty fun
not very cool though
was he like that's that seems kind of
edgy
uh crashing my best friend's mom's
funeral oh
that is tasteless dude i missed the mark
with that one i'll say so
that is not a place to joke
[Laughter]
giving kim jong-un a tesla wait a minute
he doesn't need that come on he's rich
he's he's a dictator he kills people
david that's not something to joke about
oh there's descriptions
chipotle gift card inside of
the mystery package
uh the one about the crashing my best
friend's mom's funeral that was a lot of
fun i miss
this thank you ea for helping me
surprise some people
true
james charles does my makeup
okay so he's like he's like uh
pennywise the clown from it
he says it suits me so well
oh no
oh here's a good prank i am the messiah
god chose me as the chosen one my word
is law now thanks to seek geek
[Laughter]
interesting he is pretty close to
starting his own quote so that one's a
little close to home i feel like
oh this one's interesting ending nuclear
armistice war crimes
wow his production value went up he's
got he's got his hands on nuclear
weapons
that's got to be expensive
poke some holes in his condoms that is
not funny
that's illegal i think actually
you never saw it coming subscribe to
zayn
that's inappropriate what do you think
about that do not come
condom it's just a prank bro
that's true
oh this one was this one was way out of
line
convincing my jewish friends it's 1938
stop it
stop it i can't keep getting away with
this
that is inappropriate to joke about
david even as a prank
giving out fake food in uganda hilarious
what
why would you do that isn't there like a
famine there just give them real food
david
here they are with pig
oh here they are with pictures of
hamburgers
but not a real hamburger david that's
disgusting
they were so disappointed thank you
chipotle for sponsoring this video
and nickelodeon for providing the toys
dude
someone's got to stop this man
oh no no no no no i'm afraid to even
click this one
you guys
i'm afraid to even click this one
you don't think so
do you see that click that one
[Laughter]
can i describe it no
just move on
he said i'll describe it he says
going on my own anti-bullying bullying
tour outside of high school
with some kind of
i didn't this is so inappropriate
how about this one can i click this one
yeah that one oh no
here well this is david i mean let's
my airplane landed in a terrible spot
unforgettable
david that is so [ __ ] out of
that is just not okay
you know
dude
i am disgusted by
it and finally cutting holes in my
friend's parachutes
can't believe how fast he plops
subscribe to jeff
yeah this this anti-bullying tour is
pretty outrageous honestly
wow
yeah so david's back everybody so
enjoy the ride
so much to look forward to yeah
oh you guys okay there's one more before
we get to the snack segment these are
all good stuff so just trust me on this
jeff tubin
he what network did he work for dan abc
something or cnn
well this clip is from him getting hired
at cnn he he uh
previously just worked for uh new york
times
so this is a journal a new yorker or
something a journalist yes and they were
having some kind of meeting
yeah zooming
he's going to the bathroom
oh okay
there ha
ian needs to go to the bathroom
everybody
oh zap okay yeah don't put this on me
sorry i'm totally misunderstood you're
good ian wait why do i have a weird
feeling that we talked about this no we
did okay but this is an update okay okay
i'm just like so jeff toobin is a
reporter during a meeting
because he didn't realize his camera was
on but he's on a meeting
and he's
let's say
pleasuring himself right fully nude
feverishly
during a call meeting
and it became this big story he's like
this respected journalist too so it was
super odd so here
now
this is the worst this is like the worst
thing i've ever seen so he comes out on
cnn to apologize to the world
and this is maybe the most cringe thing
i've ever seen in my life
this is news by the way
bringing in cnn chief legal analyst
jeffrey toobin to talk about this and
more hi jeffrey hello allison it's been
a while it has been a while indeed i
feel like we should address
um what's happened in the months since
we've seen you since some of our viewers
may not know what has happened so uh i
guess i'll recap i'll do the honors
this is a lot you guys know it's coming
right
you know what's coming
yep yourself okay
um in october you were on a zoom call
with your colleagues from the new yorker
magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time you were
caught masturbating on camera
i got to give it up to this guy's libido
like he's old and he's he's got he's
like i got two minutes of free time i
need to go beat one out
that's intense for an old man
i haven't had a libido like that since i
was like a teenager it's like i gotta
beat one out i have two minutes of free
time
you know what i mean that's pretty
impressive dude
uh you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn do i have all that right um you
got it all right seth why are they doing
it
why are they doing this though
it's such a public humiliation what to
say
okay so let's start there
um to quote jay leno
what the hell were you thinking well
obviously i wasn't thinking very well or
very much and um it was something that
was inexplicable to me i think one point
i i wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think other people could see me
thought that you had turned off your
camera correct i thought that i had
turned off the zoom call now that's not
a defense this was deeply moronic and
indefensible but
i mean that that is part of that that is
part of the story um and you know i have
spent this seven subsequent months
miserable months in my life i can
certainly
confess
i'm trying to be a better person i mean
in therapy
oh look at you just jerked off it's like
it's not that big it's not like he
didn't kill anyone he just got beaten
he thought he turned the camera off but
you like you got to be careful bro you
don't need therapy it's not like we
don't need to like publicly like flog
you
you've got caught beating off but the
problem is as an older as a man who's
been around this is a cnn legal analyst
you gotta know to turn the camera point
the camera away
don't ever touch yourself in front of a
camera on or off that's the rule
i mean it's a little more than that if
they were having a meeting no the
meeting was over it was over she said it
was over but the zoom was still on here
let's go back i want all the details on
this tubing
i'm here live
what has happened so
uh i guess i'll recap i'll do the honors
you gotta watch this again help yourself
okay
um
just like i did to my [ __ ]
i helped myself to my [ __ ]
uber
you were on a zoom call with hey a b is
they see down all the way steaming
your colleagues from the new yorker
magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time you were
caught masturbating
they took a break for several minutes
and the skype whipped it out it's
inappropriate well at least just go
don't be in front of the camera
sometimes look humans are disgusting and
sometimes they just you have urges and
like just don't do it in front of the
camera i'm saying i'm impressed by the
man's libido don't get me wrong do you
think he was staring at one of his
co-workers though or something weird
that's why it's inappropriate because
you don't know
oh
and everyone on the call though
can you imagine watching that go down
no do not come
he's debated that direct command from
the vice president
yeah this is one of the craziest things
i've seen on live television
on camera uh you were subsequently fired
from that job after 27 years of working
there so you're saying he does need
therapy we need to fix jeff toobin
i mean maybe i don't know we need to fix
you jeff
stop just like when god calls down jeff
stop touching yourself
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn do i have all that right um you
got it all right sad to say
okay so let's start look at this dude in
the back just like get a load of this
[ __ ] there's a dude standing right here
just judging
you see this guy i'm gonna come this
guy's like what the hell right there yo
look at this guy he's got a front row
seat what the hell were you thinking
well obviously am i crazy thinking very
well or oh my god
um it was something that was
inexplicable to me i think one point i i
wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think other people could see me
you thought that you had turned off your
camera correct i thought that this guy
has not looked the way once
you love that he's just focused i had
turned off the zoom call now that's not
a defense this was deeply moronic and
indefensible but he got it i mean that
that is part of that that is hard
[Music]
what do you guys think about this is
this a understandable mistake or or un
undefendable he should have you got to
know not to do that in front of the
camera you got to know not to yeah how
[ __ ] stupid are you i mean on a call
i mean he's an old man he's probably got
kids and [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i mean regardless of
his age like
well you i feel like
i've never known about this rule
oh god you don't beat it in front of a
camera i mean like
you're waiting
camera your phone has a camera
yeah i'm not gonna oh my mom's calling
oh we're supposed to get a call from my
mom
what we're talking about yeah it's uh
she wants to talk about this i hope not
my mom wanted to call in because she
heard the
cringe stories
and my mom tells me i've got the best
story
she hypes it up like crazy yeah here
she's she's internet she's interested i
was like okay mom i'll let you call
i want to hear her story
all right but mom are you here
i'm sending her the link right now
calling your phone okay well yeah she's
calling me
mom call mom if you're watching called
she had messaged me and
she's calling me it's funny i am live
doing a show mom i'm not going to pick
up your call maybe i would
but like amy you you you got to know
not to do that what do you mean you
don't know about this role
i mean so you guys like if you're using
your phone you cover the camera or
no if i'm on like a call oh yeah yeah
if i've if there's some kind of call or
something you have to like quadruple
check that that's not yes oh so that's
why you always got up and go to the
bathroom maybe you turn your camera off
during our zoom call yeah that's why get
a tube in yourself
[Laughter]
stop
i cringe at this whole tubing thing
because my person who've been on the
tube my no my the meat tube the meat no
the uh
because the tube in uh
situation when it first came up probably
was my most embarrassing moment on the
show because i got duped and i put the
wrong video in the document
for the last time we talked about it
yeah i thought it was like a
filtered version of the video but i
guess it was just some kind of uh
fake video but yeah i literally don't
know what you just said
i'm glad no one else remembered
when we first talked about this when it
first happened
yeah i thought i had the video on the
doc it was a fake video it was a fake
remember that oh what was the video it
doesn't matter it was it was fake it was
fake what the hell fake what do you mean
fake did anyone watch it we watched it
on the show you guys just put links in
willy-nilly
there was a
even this was like a whole debate it
became like a whole thing on the episode
you don't have any recollections no okay
well
we've been we've been down this road
okay let's not relitigate it so we are
currently waiting for my mom
to call in with her embarrassing story
and of course i want her opinion on the
jeff tubin fiasco as well right
um my mom
who is going trying to figure out how to
use zoom this could be a while
i tested with her yesterday
but is the other one texting with her
now
yeah i just i yes okay she's got the
link by the way bo burnham had a whole
song about
and his new special inside
about how he's got a call with his mom
and it's like this it's like
i got a call with my mom her thumb is
over the camera
it's just like all this you know the
[ __ ] you deal with when you call your
mom
how her thumb was over the camera for
the whole time and he's trying to
explain to her not to put her thumb over
the camera
you know
very funny stuff
i gotta watch it
um let me read these messages by my mom
i'm sure they're interesting
let's see
hi dan it's donna i just left the
restaurant i'm sitting in my car i don't
want to drive knowing you're going to
call how on time are you guys
should i drive back it's hot sitting in
the car
is she sitting in her car right now in
the hot car use the ac mom what the hell
my parents are so cheap they literally
won't put on the ac
they refuse to put to start the engine
and run the ac
[Music]
i swear my parents are the cheapest
people in the live
and they're not tight trust me i know
they're not on a tight situation
they can afford to run the ac in their
five percent covers that
yeah you want to try calling her back
live on the show you want me just to get
my phone out i mean scholar
what
she may
she got the link i mean what's the big
deal what does it literally just click
the link mom just click the link
right yes
correct but if i call her it's gonna
distract her even more
right
then it's gonna if i call her it's gonna
add another 30 minutes
this is what she's doing right now with
her glasses she's got her glasses on and
she's like how the [ __ ] do i do this
thing i clicked the link and then my dad
said
donna just give me the phone no gary i
can do this how the [ __ ] does this work
click the [ __ ] link
hello
it's not working
that's literally what's happening in the
car
my dad's sitting there like this
[Music]
i don't wanna just click the link i
don't think your dad's there because
she she gave me the whole explanation
she was going to lunch with her her
girlfriends and then and then she ran
out to her car
how is this complicated there's a link
on the chat that you click
dan any update from her
no i mean you're seeing everything i'm
seeing we're in the same group chat okay
let me call her
she's like ethan i'm dying of heat well
turn on the ac
i've got the windows down she's in
woodland hills it's like 110 degrees
hi mom just click the link
all right
click the link
yes
all right hold on no rush
no rush we're just on a live show
with 108 000 people watching
oh no i
jeez
for some reason it's not coming up
shoot ethan you see a link on your phone
the dan sent
no i don't she doesn't see a link dan
oh here we go vip call yep that's the
whatsapp group and then dan sent a zoom
link if you go ahead and click that
okay okay all right explain just to
describe everything as it's happening
well i'm in my car
[Music]
air conditioner on yeah it's just it's
like 100 degrees it's like 100 degrees
in woodland hills why wouldn't you use
the ac in your car
i'm not in woodland hills i'm in
calabash well regardless of where you
are it's clearly hot
okay it is hot and i okay here here's
the parking lot
i'm gonna pull into the parking spot
okay
so you're driving
yeah well yeah
um
junior high school
went to lunch
okay really kind of cool that is cool
and everybody looks really really good
oh look at there's a nice change spot in
the parking spot
okay
so please enter my name my name is
entered okay all right we got the link
mom you're you're the part you're parked
in this in the shade are you gonna put
on your ac
well i got the ac on and here's a spot
that's under a tree
okay wait we see you in the room
okay so let's see if this works dan's
gonna
yeah okay i'm about to hang up okay
and then we'll bring you in by zoom
okay i'm gonna hang up all right go
ahead dan
that's some real high level mom [ __ ]
right there yeah go for it what the hell
are you waiting for me for
[Music]
okay okay thank you
i was like don't wait for me i'm
spent like 29 minutes on a live show
waiting for my mom to connect
says uh joining
oh he is
yeah joining mom is parked in the shade
somewhere in calabasas with the top down
oh
she's gone she's gone just disappeared
all right how about much longer i know
it's like funny kind of but like how
much longer can we keep this up
let me try one more time
because i do really want to hear her
story
can you hear me hey we lost you what
happened
[Music]
mom
hello
hello
you it's not a good spot yeah the shade
is not a good spot you've got no
connection there
oh she's probably in the hills of
calabasas where there's no reception
do you have why how's your how's your 4g
on your phone you got a good reception
there
yeah clearly not she's talking and
nothing's happening
oh boy
all right
[Music]
well we can just move on and if i see
her pop into zoom i'll let her in
so let's go move we'll get her on later
we'll get her on a little bit
i like how she planned this out it was
such a big deal for her
and she's driving around calabasas with
her top down
[Music]
all right so we got the international
food well we're gonna get my mom on
don't you guys worry we're gonna get her
on
so let's start let's get the food out
we've got treats from all over i would
say specifically southeast asia
it's primarily japan and korean snacks
you know they got like
not to insult their snack game but to me
they're really creative
oh
to me these snacks are wild as
hell so we're going to give i'm going to
go to the bathroom so as they set up ela
you're uh
really you're the host you're really
doing that to me i have to pay what can
i do
oh that's so cute
hello kitty
oh we've probably got a bunch of
donations let me uh
let me take a look real quick
let's see
there's none in the uh recent queue but
i'm going to load it up real quick
um
[Music]
i'm 16 and my dad has had cancer for the
last three years
and i recently turned terminal he has a
few days left and you all have been my
escape thank you
i'm really sorry
um
terminal
cancer is probably the worst thing you
can
have to go through
that's what we had with my dad so
can definitely relate
and it's super difficult
and
not much i can say to make you feel
better right now probably
um you know the ones we're pointing over
here you can't have
okay
because you're pregnant
um
love you guys and the crew
thank you
uh the crew couples should totally do
play
should totally play last couple standing
last couple standing i don't know what
that is
hilah can you show your sweater it's um
it's this
sample hasn't been made yet
probably come out later this year but
it's very fresh
cardigan
and i think it's pretty cool i'm also
wearing um
this is another sample it's a new
bracelet and necklace that we're working
on that i really love it's like
handcuffs
and i just love that it works so well
that's hot
like listen to the sound
it's like so real oh [ __ ]
you lock somebody up with that for real
yeah
oh that's hot
um ethan's hoodie is going to come out
next week
so
because i just saw a comment about that
[Music]
wow
oh by the way about the memes i've been
dying at all the teddy got crane
memes oh we should make several nine of
those
and it's still happening we're still not
sleeping full nights anymore like that's
just out the window it's honestly even
worse
in a way than when he was a newborn
because
he's waking up a few times so he gets
both of us like it's just it's just
i woke up this morning and i was like oh
god he didn't i didn't worse where's
theodore did he sleep and then i look at
you he's sleeping with yola yeah and you
know what happens to me so he comes to
our room and it must be so silent
because i have no idea that he's there
he's a little nervous
the dogs kind of start to make a noise
so i probably wake up from the dogs but
i don't see anything so i'm like
going back to sleep
and this happened to me again i turned
to the side and then he's sitting there
silently it's scary and he's just
staring at me
oh you know what's cute about theodore
on the theater updates he had his first
day of school yesterday yeah how about
that for great well it's preschool
oh the phone
came
the phone went black
it's just a little class in preparation
for preschool
can you cut to it
oh my god it still works so lucky though
we can show close-ups of our snacks now
sick
so
these look amazing
so let's get start who's who's going to
um lead this because i have no idea i'll
hold this well somebody's got to lead us
through the snack journey
someone taking the lead on this
yeah um also your mom your mom just
joined
her yeah she's uh well she's in
their camera's off though and it doesn't
look like she's connected to audio yet
okay well but she's on the zoom call now
so we've made we've made something in
about an hour i'll be able to talk to my
mom right yeah so where do you want to
start ela
you see something you like
who's going to be
is someone going to be guiding us we can
do it it's got all the echo on the back
uh let's start with this
okay
that looks really good so here you want
to get a close-up of it
so this is a popular snack from korea it
already i think it's already working is
it working because yeah okay
this is a popular snack in korea called
turtle chips chocolate churro chips bruh
bruh moment
yeah those look
bomb
gotta say
well are we using this shot or am i just
holding this
this is i can't see on the phone wait
it's upside down
i think we need to fix this well here
just
yeah but it's not gonna work
can i see it on the phone though what
i'm showing
this drill ship
hmm
got like funnel cake flavor i love it
i mean that one's just good wow
okay this one's good
let's do weird [ __ ] though
like for example
this is horrific
i mean i can't eat those by the way
this one's scary you guys
they're little like dried crabs here
we gotta get a shot of this
um
ooh
ooh smell it i don't know i already
smelled it
here give me give me that
so look at this
am i just supposed to eat this hole i
can't i feel so bad for the little crab
i see it
it's it's just a little crab
and so the info on this one is
japanese baked
crabs they just sell them by the bag bro
that's some callous [ __ ]
these crabs are worthless
how do they even just
i don't know that i can do this you guys
somebody should do it first and tell me
yeah i'm not eating that
i'll do it exactly here show this sheila
here i got you right here
you'll show this
let's go here's the eyes and everything
oh wow there's nothing oh everything
flavor it's not it's not like the worst
it's kind of sweet
i'm going in a switch you're saying
there's eyeballs on it here we don't
like those eyeballs on it i'm going in
eyeballs
oh eggs
i'm just gonna eat this tasty one yeah
you can do you enjoy yourself this is a
very odd flavor all right i'm going in
i'm like not i don't eat shellfish i'm
like this is just not my thing
i just i don't like to see the details i
don't want to see i don't want to know
how it's you know what i mean i like to
i like to live in la la land where i
pretend animals aren't actually killed
for me right yeah they're just this
absolutely and i feel actually makes me
feel bad when i can see the face and the
legs and stuff
i just want a steak from the grocery
store and then i have to know about all
the inhumanity that goes into check this
out i can do a nail update
excuse me i'm about to uh
oh yeah that is pretty cool show your
nails off you why is it like a reverse
it's moving in the reverse way you know
what i mean this is your the camera
anyway yeah
are we seeing it
guys
literally what's happening
okay i'm gonna eat the crab
okay
this music seriously
are you trying to show your nails i'm so
confused no he said flip the phone but
no i didn't do anything okay let's just
do the eating yeah here we go
oh
it's very odd
it's so
intended and crunchy and
seafoody
i can't do it
are you spitting it out
hey guys
is that bad
it's just so weird to be eating an
animal like a piece of like a chip
[Laughter]
it's literally just a potato chip
it tastes kind of farmy do you know what
i mean
it's like sea and farmy yeah
no
nope don't bring it near me i mean it's
like the whole body it's like it's gotta
have guts and poop in there yeah i feel
like i'm eating poop like
we just ate it
i don't like it
are we liking the music because i saw
how much the music is not it
guys show you guys eat it come on i
wanna see all your reactions
uh i'm vegetarian i'm not gonna eat the
uh crab who's going zack ate one i
already ate one
i don't know if it's hell or not
well shellfish isn't right depends which
shack you
yeah ask does yours say today he says no
oh all right
next up these are dude this i was
reaching for
cheeto churros dude the koreans loved
the churro thing because wasn't that
also true all right yeah i mean so the
koreans know how to make these snacks
so that's what that is
i love the sweet cheeto
alright
there's a lot of seafood i'm just really
not good with seafood like
whatever this is i'll just tell you
right now it's not happening
i think it's squid
oh god
i can't be the only one eating this it's
just not my thing
these are better though
so thick
we're not doing this segment if you're
just going to be chewing and eating
everything the burger's so far away from
me
all right what's next you guys should
show the drinks how you carbonate them
they have a carbonation ball at the top
you take the cap and you push it inwards
and it'll carbonate the drink really
yeah
okay so this is uh
this is from
so there's no carbonation in it yeah
it's a little carbonation ball at the
top so what you do is you push the top
in
okay do i push this whole thing in yeah
here you want to get it close or here
all good
i'll get a close-up
guys i feel this segment is kind of a
disaster i'm being honest i don't know
if this is good for a live podcast
am i not strong enough for this simple
thing okay ready i don't know that this
shot helps
am i crazy
[Applause]
push it dead in the center
[Applause]
it can't be that hard can it
no i'm not gonna allow you to do it on
top of me
oh you're using i'll stop it i can do
that
yeah i can do that
okay i can do that
oh all right
i got this i got exciting news
my mom
well
oh there's my mom in her car in this
game
we can see her hello can you hear me
yes yes
oh my god
i don't know that you have a great
reception where you are
well
oh my god i'm chatting
was your ac on
no
i mean i'd want my car to just
you have to go home and get on the
internet we can't understand anything
yeah just drive home
mom
what did you do
is not good
yeah i wanted to go to japan
oh so you're don't okay well go
go somewhere else
the internet is not good
somewhere else let me see if it'll work
can i put the top down
you think that'll help with the internet
maybe try that
all right i'll put the top down
your father was screaming at me to put
the top up
because the signal will get a more
direct line into her phone
right mom
mom
mom why are we putting the top down
mom why are we putting the top down just
to get a better signal all right
is that the thing i know i thought you
could hear it better
so now you're on my
phone on the car
can you hear me better
[Music]
it's so much better i can hear
oh it god
hey mom
mom why don't you tell me your story
[Music]
yeah it's way better now
oh my god
oh my god
are you driving right now
yeah i'm in the parking lot
okay
can you hear me
mom why don't you tell me the story
okay thank god
dad if you're watching just
listen
let's let's end the call
okay can you hear me now
i mean i could do a whole show like this
but
let's end the call with my mom
i'll call her
tell her
okay so
you can hear me
oh she's trying to tell the story now
i don't think we're going to be able to
hear her story like yeah
okay mom um
so
the internet connection wasn't great
there i'll be honest
all right
do you want to talk can she just tell
the story like this um
dan can you hear her okay it's okay
you want to tell the story check can you
hear me
can you hear her yeah
she's coming through the mic literally
okay go ahead with the story you can do
it like this
okay all right so
the most recent most embarrassing
uh thing that happened to me was
maybe like 10 years ago
and
dad and i were on vacation
and i can't remember if it was in hawaii
or we were in puerto vallarta but we
were at a really nice
hotel
and you know your dad likes to sunbathe
and i do not
so dad's out basking in the sun and i
went to the small
pool
it was kind of like a jacuzzi
and there was only
a couple another couple in the jacuzzi
besides me
and i was wearing one of those speedo
bathing suits you know the kind that
swimmers wear
because you know at my age i'm not
wearing a bikini anymore so
i was wearing the speedo and they're
made out of what are they made out of
spandex
yeah bathing suits they're real stretchy
well it had been a long time since i
bought a bathing suit so it was you know
fairly old
and i get in the water and i'm splashy
splashy and having a good time and
there's this other couple that's kind of
nestling together in the corner the
girls on the on the husband's lap or
boyfriend's lap
and i decided that i was done i was
going to get up and go over to you where
your father was so i get up and of
course the pool water is like up to your
waist it's not deep
so i get up but my bathing suit
kind of stayed down
we likely stretched out
so i took off it was like a big balloon
you know filled with water
and i was i was naked
oh my god
so i was incredibly embarrassed in front
of this other couple in their mouths of
course
i tried to pull my bathing suit up the
best i could
and run out of the pool mom
you and dad you need to be buying new
stuff
you've got this swimming suit that's so
old it's falling off your body when
you're flashing these poor people
well i mean
you know girls hate to buy bathing suits
and mom there's a certain thing
there's a certain point when you need to
accept that it's time for did you buy
did you abandon that swimming sword or
did you wear it again
no i threw it away and i just
hit the hotel i put it in the trash can
yeah it took for you committing like a
crime of public community too oh my god
well you know your mother's pretty thin
but still
you know i'm this
naked old lady
oh my god i just wanted to die
that's all i have to say that's pretty
bad
that was good that was a good one
that was one of those garment
malfunction
stories
any other ones you want to share since i
got you on the phone
well
i had another garment malfunction but
this was this was when i was
really young i was in junior high this
before i met your father
and you know grandpa jerry and grandma
ann
had this really nice
house in chatsworth and we had a big
swimming pool
and i had my then boyfriend and his
brother and some other friends over
and then my cousin marla from chicago
who you know was just out
she was over and we were swimming in the
swimming pool there's another swimming
pool in debacle
and i was wearing a bikini
and i'm swimming around and finally my
cousin comes up to me she says donna
your bathing suit is up to your neck and
i look down and my boobies are sticking
out
oh my god
i screamed why the hell didn't you tell
me my god
you know so i
you know i pulled my bathing suit down
and that was the end of it but nobody
said a thing she's like i'm driving i'm
swimming around like la dee da
no one says anything to me
you know incredible
yeah like someone has a booger hanging
out of their nose
well listen uh thank you for sharing
i appreciate
to be honest with you i think
i'm afraid you trying to call in is
probably more
the most entertaining part but i love
that
all right mom thank you good luck and uh
wherever you're going on the day
and are you going to put on the ac
are you going to put on the ac are you
going to put the top down
the top is down i'm putting the ac on
with the top down
[Laughter]
okay we bought we bought my mom a purse
for mother's day we got we got our gucci
purse
and i have to say i think
i think that's the happiest i've ever
seen
[Laughter]
like genuinely at my wedding i don't
think you were that happy
i should have seen that pure ecstasy on
her face when we gave her that first
but i'm happy because i didn't you know
the chat wants us to tell her that they
love her oh chad loves you mom
oh that's so sweet i love you too
i would never you know buy a purse like
that for myself absolutely no
that was like pretty incredible but all
my girlfriend said to me when i sat down
they all said ah i love your purse
and i said yes my beautiful
daughter-in-law and my handsome son
bought this for me for mother's day and
everyone's standing in unison
it's the five percent
yeah don't worry it comes it comes from
the five percent friend of me scott so
all the money
all right mom mom i'm gonna stop you
there
because i know my mom gets real heated
about this whole thing and i don't want
to say something she'll regret live
all right no i want my my listeners are
yet okay mom i'll talk to you all right
all right i love you okay all right
all right
oh brother jonathan everyone donna klein
donna save the segment
hey
real quick somebody donated 200 euros
wow to say i want ethan's hoodie when
can i get it oh my god well
i'll just send you the one off my back
for that much
all right yeah you just could have
bought several videos
10 am this thursday yeah
next week next week yeah i mean yeah
next week well there you go last juan
standing
is there any other comment
uh there's a few um donna is an absolute
legend yeah a lot a lot of praise for
donna here
that comes here trying to connect
was one of the funniest things i was
crying like you couldn't recreate a
perfect mom moment if you tried yeah the
top the humming the sun right into the
camera
shot from under her face it was just
amazing when she's like hold on let me
see if this makes it better
it's just pure
chaos it got so much worse
uh
lauren donated 25 bucks said thanks for
making my week so much better one of my
55 rescue horses
had major abdom abdominal
surgery and my week's been pretty crappy
listening to you guys is really bringing
up my week you have 55 horses
wow dude
you're like a horse savior
love what you're doing with the horse
huh keep it up that's a lot of horses
what do you do with all this
thank you for that
thank you so um so let's blast through
these things because i don't want to put
it to waste but we got to keep the pace
up okay so maybe you want to put this on
me i don't think this helps do we really
need this shot no we don't i feel like i
feel like a mom
dan you made kind of a grossed out face
a second ago what was that about okay so
do you guys have some of these chips
they just look like regular pictures
yeah yeah i've been eyeing these okay
give that a shot and tell me what you
think so let me read the description go
ahead ela these are honey butter chips
from korea these koreans have dude take
their snacks seriously
love it i mean
i'm not repulsed
i feel like it's it ends rough it and
it's kind of weird these are dank these
are
i feel like this is the worst potato
chip ever honey butter chips i'm not and
i'm not think i would have dressed
potato chip is not a good not good it
tastes like a rotten sour cream and
onion chip it's like a sour cream and
onion chip that you opened the bag two
years ago and you just found it in the
couch yeah dude i think they're good so
classy and nice but i agree i'm not what
is this one that's kind of fluffy what
this is um can i see myself then it's
still on oh yeah here i'll switch it
this one is a shrimp chip
another from korea shrimp shrimp juice
i've already had one cheers
give it a shot
it tastes great
really
these are dang too i don't like it oh
there's a shrimp
yeah shrimp chip
what do you guys think of the shrimp
chips totally it's horrific i [ __ ] with
it
dude you like everything that's good
dude i'm not like
okay i'm moving on to the custard cake
how can this be bad what is what's the
story here
there's no ew
i can stand correct
what's the story with this one
because there's no info on the pack
it's
best choice the best choice yes
what does that mean yeah what does that
mean
oh okay
they're popular in korea
oh it looks like an egg yolk
it tastes like alcohol like smell right
oh yeah oh i know what you mean
it tastes like it tastes like eggnog
with brandy in it
in a cake form what are these
these are wasabi gram peas oh dude this
is what it this is what it is can you
fix that
yeah i got it
oh wasabi peas i love those
oh
hit this chocolate bar is it good
no shrimp no [ __ ] in shrimp i know it's
weird just get a normal snack without
like
shrimp vowels yo wasabi peas what's up
wasabi peas those are hard dude
no that's awesome
but
okay
you're something you want to say to me
can you watch your chewing
and we're doing a show i just enjoy i'm
ah
let's be honest this segment is already
kind of a dumpster fire my chewing is
not gonna ruin
well
it might
you're right the chewing doesn't help
these smelly peas are good great i don't
know
this is really good does anyone know
what this thing is
it's like i think that's what i want
dude
is it squid i think that's dried squid
or something where's
okay so this is dried squid
from korea
and this is good you're saying
yeah these are all my fishy jerky
i'm gonna hate it try it try it
smells super fishy
oh no it's already in my teeth i bit it
wrong it's in my teeth i'm panicking
[Music]
[Laughter]
no good
it's not that bad actually really
that's pretty good actually
because i hate squid too
i'm fighting it because i don't want to
like it but it's actually not that bad
i'm gonna try it no no no no no no no no
no no no people saying chew louder in
the uh no
don't read stuff like let him chew are
you the producer of the show i don't
mind that i'm just i'm just reading the
feedback from the fans no i no people uh
yeah he's technician
right
let's keep it going here we go
i need i really need someone to lead to
to
lead this to be honest with you guys
yeah
i think that's what we're missing here
um here
this is um
this is the most important
item that we have here okay there's just
more and more i'm just getting
overwhelmed here
thank god
thank you thank you thank you
no please get the put the crabs in the
ocean where they belong
take these
these i think we ate these are the
butternuts
these are really cute this little
toilets
whatever's happening here yeah
take this please sam
thank you
and then what was this this is like
avocado seaweed
yeah that was just kelp
nope those are kind of bomb no that's
good nope you're serious no
all right
all
[Music]
no with the toilets
i have a toilet
so we need the explanation you know how
this works right
we have a toilet
we have water and we have a toilet
i have no idea what's happening right
now but these are good
so with the toilets
you take these powders right
you mix them together yeah you pour them
in the back of the toilet okay and then
you flush it in
oh i'm flushing something so here let's
get it open yeah there you go bring that
in yeah there you go so we have a toilet
so open the back this has to be japanese
right yeah oh [ __ ] it comes in the the
tank yep okay so open that up and we
pour this in
some kind of powdered substance
no i'm spitting now that the other one
in there too right now i'm gonna be
only in japan why why would i want to be
drinking out of a toilet but okay i'm
here
it's cute yeah
it's a little tiny toilet here look at
the box dude yeah i'm not drinking
trying to drink [ __ ] yeah the packaging
is like an important you're gonna need
that straw that just dropped okay i'll
grab that in a moment okay look at the
directions on the back so we got the
powder so we put in the two powders and
then we pour in with some water
is that the next step okay let's get the
water
okay hold on hold on their camera's here
so let's not reach in front of the
camera okay i'll do it okay
okay so here we go pour that water into
the tank
into the tank
perfect too much water
is it going to go down
i hope so
so where's the lid oh god
yeah i got the lid
oh it flushes yes oh [ __ ] that's crazy
all right so now i'm going to open this
yep i'm going to flush it
right
you press it down i'm pushing everywhere
it actually flushes oh really yeah stir
it with the straw in the toilet okay
so here you go okay oh it's gone down
quite a bit
okay that is literally disgusting
that's a flooded toilet yeah that's like
when that makes me think of [ __ ] and
piss when it comes out of the top of
this so take a big uh take a big sip
here we go cheers everybody to your
health
sorry
what do you think not bad
not bad
yum
sewage
get a shot of this
[Laughter]
yum you should try one milo
do you want me to make the other one
here right here sure you know what let's
move on we saw it yeah we tried it
that was fun
it's like a fizzy drink like a
very tasty
okay so what's next
um
[Music]
what's what's going on with these can i
just eat these
you dip those in the jelly and then you
roll them in the sprinkles this is an
apple you want to film this hila and our
so i'm dipping this in the jelly
i'm sorry it's like this
it moves in the reverse of the direction
that i'm actually moving so that's why
it's super awkward
i think i know why
there you go okay
okay so
all right i've got my apple
covered schmutz and now i'm gonna candy
it up
such a fun little experience there it is
[Music]
you want me to make you one elo
is this stuff okay for me to eat you
think
not just sugar okay i think it's fine
here you go
your very own candy apple
good
very good
this one's got to be japanese too right
it's really good
that was japanese yeah all the colorful
crazy dipping and yeah
wow it's so good
i love pizza and i love people not now
papa
here's another one i think you just dip
can't believe you weren't about this
these are awesome literally hate it so
much
you want to get a shot of this silo
i'll make you one
so this is another japanese treat
it looks like the kirby villains treat
it's like a icicle treat and then we
powder it up let's go
cheers
oh gooey
gluey
gluey
gluey doesn't sound good he has no pizza
experience
what am i eating right now
is this gum
gum
i don't think this is edible
um
i don't actually want that one i want
another one of these
all of the ingredients are just sugar so
i think you're good
i don't think that's edible it's sugar
corn syrup
here's someone else try one
i swear to god it's not edible
i don't think i can swallow that
i keep chewing it
i was starting to break down now
takes a minute though like i've never
had such a chewing experience
what
okay i understand you're concerned now
no it's starting to break down but it's
like a
i never experienced that before who
wants to hit this this one's really
interesting yours
it's good
like try that it's weird but it's really
good
i don't know why i don't want it all
right what's next
this is gonna this is kind of the
ultimate
all right
you definitely want to see this
wow the serving tray
oh
what tiny hamburgers yes
what what is this
well oh did you make these sam yes yeah
they're called pop and cooking
this is a japanese snack and it's diy so
you have to build these yourself
it's like
here look at this salmon ian had like a
little uh yeah
so you have to put a pack
mix it make all the individual p is it
supposed to taste like what it looks
like no
oh i
don't imagine that it tastes like a
hamburger i hope it doesn't taste like a
hamburger
yeah i don't know what's worse i'm weird
so here's a little french fry and
ketchup too you want to get a shot of
this hello things are so cute
look at that the japanese are on a whole
other level when it comes to everything
man this is what i'm saying so here i've
got a toy french fry
right here yolo
so we have everything here is candy
apparently so i've got the candy french
fry my dip in the candy ketchup
everything looks so real
oh there's pepper
no there's no no no that's that's the
soda the soda and here's water that you
make the soda with yes oh for real but
you got to get this ela so this i get a
sodi pop so here it looks like pepper
okay so here let me put water
carefully carefully and here's my soda
pop is it supposed to carbonate oh there
it goes yeah look it's fizzy and [ __ ]
like why i mean lude god bless their
creativity but like who is this for
because it tastes like crap
kids
goodies it's like candy that tastes good
but it's so cute so hit that soda and
let me tell you
tell us what you think
it almost tastes like soda but then not
at all
these fries are horrible is it all gonna
taste like that so here's my burger elo
they're made out of different powders so
i don't think we need this shot for
everything it's like
i think it helps does it because it's so
small it's like what do you guys think
i mean just
it's like blurry yeah it's blurry okay
here we go
ah
no
i don't like this
i don't like it i don't like it
okay moving on to the ice cream treat
this is pretty impressive you guys
look at that
[Laughter]
chocolate donut
right
cute look how cute it is there's a hair
in it y'all
this one's actually good yeah i'm gonna
try this one yeah this one i like
i like it
we got it i like it look at all the
detail yeah
tiny little donut
actually popping that one yeah i'm
popping
yep yep yep
i like it i'm trying one yeah hit one of
those the donuts are good banana milk
no
banana milk this is is this korean yeah
yeah it's very popular especially for
kids
okay it's a milk that tastes like banana
i like it
i do like it actually
pretty good this looks disgusting bro
what is this one
yeah so that was another one that um
you had to like kind of make maybe work
it down
what is this well
at one point it was like a a powder
right and it got mixed together and
turned into um it appears to be like a
custard
and that's candy
so
why is it like that
hmm
i'm processing this no good it looks
like a really weird texture i don't know
you're going to like this it tastes like
smarties
that's your favorite snack it can be
right is it smarties when we did the
candy tear list i thought you were like
shockingly
maybe you might like this because it
tastes like smarties but
that texture
that ain't right that looks like a bunny
egg
let's skip that one
i'm just extra worried to eat weird
stuff that's it wow
wow
that was yeah i know he was crazy he was
worried that one of them
you this is the the resting place of the
crab i ate by the way what i spit out
the crab yeah yeah horrific
here i'll take it thank you
can i get some more
yeah thank you guys get your heart out
ian ian wants more squid
she's really all about that huh
ian please stand up please stand up ian
with the squad
ian please stand up well thank you guys
for watching through this
wild
wild show today
well what else is there is there any
interesting comments or donations
you should go over someone keep an eye
on that
what do we got
if chewing sounds bother you then you
are a weak human
and natural selection will get you sorry
i don't know what to tell you it's not
that deep law
look it doesn't bother me but i know it
for some people they just really dislike
the sound so
it's the worst thing in the world well
apparently you're not fit to evolve
according to this guy
sometimes i'll be eating with someone
and it usually doesn't bother me but
sometimes i'll be sitting next to
someone and it's like
somebody said yikes is right gang this
segment is literally immersion therapy
for my
mesophyll phonia which what's that
misophonia i'm going to assume is uh
hating the sound of chewing disorder
when certain sounds trigger emotional or
physiological responses
that sounds like a you problem to be
honest but i understand what you're
saying it's you and me yeah
people keep send sending the same
comment uh play last couple standing
yeah i think they keep donating that
with spicy questions is it just a
browser thing
what is this i don't like spicy
questions i don't i don't know that
awesome there's been too much spice talk
today couple first couple is that a web
browser game or what
i'll tell you i'll be the last one doing
any standing
oh
oh
does anyone know a couple's verse couple
i mean i just googled it i'm looking i'm
looking it up right now i google it i
don't see [ __ ] see a kickstarter
yeah
if you're asking us to answer like sex
questions it's not happening
but i will tell you ila likes when i
poop in her butt stop
we poop and we pull back and forth
one of my routines from a movie i forget
this kid he's chatting with girls online
he's like eight
and he goes
i want to poop back and forth
you poop in my butt and then i'll poop
in your butt forever
kinky talk i gotta find that
god it's like so it's just one of my
favorites ever
um
you poop in my butt and i'll poop in
your butt somebody asked uh i don't know
if lovebot is single but you would you
allow the bot to date
um the robot itself we're not talking
about love we're talking oh the robot um
i don't know he would need a chaperone
that's an expensive equipment to let out
that's true
i need i need to get insurance on that
bot
i think it's a little bit it's probably
a little late to try and uh
so this is this is my favorite uh
i don't know why i just found i if she
likes i haven't watched it a minute so
maybe it's not as funny as i remember
let's all but what is it from
it's from a movie called
me
and you and everyone we know
2005.
but it's specifically this scene that
always cracked me up and i haven't seen
it in a while
so maybe it's not as funny as i remember
let's all decide okay okay here we go
i guessed what kind of bosom she had
problems man
why is it a man does everyone just make
stuff up on these things it's probably a
man pretend to be a woman okay so
picture a fat guy with a little wiener
what's up awesome
it's a nice word for titties
where's mom
first mom what do you mean
what do you think she's doing right now
i know screwing a new boyfriend probably
i think she's buying us presents yeah
robbie right now she's probably buying
us each a car
it's a man
i think it's a woman i can tell it is
what should we write i have a big wiener
i want to poop back and forth what
what does that mean
like i'll poop into her butthole and
then she'll put back into my butthole
and then we'll just keep doing it back
and forth
with the same poop
oh my god i'm going to put that i want
to poop back and forth
oh god she's going to think we're a
crazy perverted person
you think you're
crazy tall like i always said it no
she'll never write back robbie we have
to sound like we're a man you know
that's just lame it's stupid you thought
i could do half and you've done all of
them but for this okay whatever we're
probably going to get arrested what do
you want to put like how i said it
yeah but hold
and then you will
poop it back
into my
butt
and we will
keep
doing it
back
and forth and forth
with the same
forever
[Music]
you are crazy and you are making
me very hot
anyway the movie goes on where this kid
carries on a relationship with this
person in secret
and then he ends up meeting at a place
and it's like an actual like grown-ass
woman
and she's like who are you and you're
like i'm the guy you've been chatting
with oh
man weird ass movie
what do we think pretty good very funny
thank you
still holds up
well there's nothing else to talk about
though we're just kind of how long we've
been going dan we've been going for
about two and a half hours oh okay wow
that time went by fast man
oh that snack segment was rough
fun though
well that's about it is there anything
else we should talk about
[Music]
what do you guys want to um because i
saw a few people say that we should do
the advice segment on after dark yeah i
agree
i think we i think the problem was that
a lot of the questions we got were for
trisha were yeah like super personal and
patricia so i wasn't sure
it didn't seem right to read them here
yeah so do should we make an email right
now and tell people or i guess what we
can plan for next week
um
okay
oh the old email was like frenemies
advice or something like that yeah let's
make a new email and then we'll announce
it next week but i agree i do want to do
the advice oh programming note about
next week uh
after dark will actually be on thursday
instead of the usual friday because uh
it's somebody's birthday next week
somebody
that somebody is my old ass yes sir so
uh they are
taking a three-day weekend to go
chill so we're going to do the episode a
day early so thursday next week for
after dark we're taking a family
vacation
which is really it should be fun
so theodore's coming along
yeah on the beach
nice like opens up right to the beach
and theodore loves the sand and the
water so he's and we got a kite
we got a kite we got a kite is he into
that just chilling i'm sure he's gonna
we don't know you guys are going to see
the rapids yeah we're going to cedar
rapids bro
we're going with hillary's
i got my spirit cooking all lined up oh
my god you guys there's a literal but
how is this real there's a bug swimming
in my saudi look ela no
look he's swimming around
oh there's a bug there why is this food
so it's it's cursed this food is so
cursed bro that's actually part of the
experience it's supposed to be still
alive like how did this attract a living
bug i've been sipping out of it
zach drank it
oh lee mine's really good okay
so anyway i'm kidding i'm 36 i'm
embarrassed to admit
and i spent all year i don't know if i
talked about it i spent all year
thinking i was turning 35.
i swear to god
i thought i was turning 35
it's been a weird year for you know time
with
the pandemic and quarantine and
everything so it just hits different
though when i was like at 35 i was ready
for 35 i was prepared for 35 but when i
was like oh my god i'm 36. you got that
halfway point 35 it's comfy 36 is a
little uncomfy
36 makes me a little uncomfy i'll be
honest
because 40 is like can i even make
youtube videos at 40
can we continue this or do we just pack
it up
i mean
we make a podcast i'd say on average
most podcasters are probably over 40.
that's true maybe it helps because
people are like oh he's wise he's not
some young [ __ ] sure
that makes you feel better
he doesn't i'm just kidding nothing goes
anything else you guys want to talk
about i noticed there's a scale in the
bathroom who put this yeah i saw that
too
i put it in there why'd you put that in
there you're so skinny no lena uh
brought a box of stuff from her guy's
house yesterday after she left your
guy's house and i put the scale in there
oh it's the scale from the weigh in yeah
we're doing oh i was like oh boy
you're gonna fact shaming wow take a
dump yeah
i hope this doesn't make you sound like
a douche thank you zach you know
yeah i like to i like to weigh myself
before and after pooping so that's
helpful
well guys i hope you enjoyed i thought
it was a lot of fun
i love that sketch we made with the five
percent we're definitely gonna keep that
up you know we're working on some more
sketches for next week
so do you guys have a plan for next week
episode wise yeah what people can expect
yeah so
monday we have a plan
and then
um
and then after dark thursday so i think
there's only two episodes next week am i
right yes yeah we just have two apps
next week we're still trying to figure
out that third slot for monday
um we're just really weighing a lot of
different options
but uh
next week's going to be rough because
it's you know we're missing a day
oh
guys
what can i say
it's been good times we've had my mom
we've had squids
the five percent
and most importantly jeff toobin making
an apology i forgot to ask my mom about
jeff tubin should i call her back
what she has an opinion on it i wanted
to ask her if he needed help or if he
was good
you know
did you think she's got some words of
wisdom i figured she was watching but
she's not watching i don't think so
enjoy writing i think your dad was
watching though dad are you watching uh
yeah well he was uh trying to help with
the whole uh
fiasco that was going on
so he's probably watching
let's end it here
let's let let's let jeff tubin be all
right
so we will see you on
well we might have an episode out on
monday actually it's staying corrected
and then posted tuesday we'll see
stand by we're working on the schedule
one thing for sure is that after dark
will be thursday next week yes and there
will be one episode that we'll be
working on you'll have a more definite
schedule there's obviously a lot of
changes going on here since frenemies
ended
and we are still trying to work things
out
with peace and love
so thank you guys
love you appreciate we had 3 million
today hello
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you want to eat to celebrate
you don't know i don't know are you
hungry
yes
okay you're hungry but you desire
nothing specific right it's a very
annoying feeling
yeah last night we ordered food and when
arrived you didn't even touch it it was
very weird i was starving i just wanted
that foot to be there already and when i
was there i was just like sick i just
didn't want it
was it from stress
all right
guys
we'll see you next week
next week
bye
[Music]
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene could it be poplar
you